it holds up because it's not
about something trivial the twilight
zone is about something profound deeply
profound
what makes the twilight zone different
from everything else
quality
it's good um okay
the twilight zone is
possibly the best television show ever
made uh i think there's an argument
argument that can be made for that
rod sterling never wanted to be a
science fiction writer he wanted
basically to be the arthur miller of
television
and
when he was censored when he couldn't
write about politics when he couldn't
write about race there were so many
things he wanted to write about and the
censors just would not allow it and his
work he felt his work was being turned
into meaningless crap
because of these
limitations he thought well if i do
science fiction maybe i can slide these
things past and they won't notice what
i'm actually doing
and that that's worked it worked exactly
he he ended up writing four pilot
scripts for the twilight zone before the
show got greenlit he was very determined
to uh to have that happen and um
so i think it came from the fact that
this was a man who had a lot to say
and knew how to say it
uh twilight zone just isn't about the
gimmick the gimmicks are great and the
twist endings and all of those things
are wonderful and the fact that it was
science fiction and horror and fantasy
allowed it to be universal in a way that
had he just been writing about you know
uh
ed medgar evers or something it wouldn't
have been you know because then it would
seem very dated and the writers from
that era of live television generally
are not well known you know tad moselle
or reginald rose or even patty chayefsky
had sterling stayed in live tv
and not created twilights and he'd
probably be forgotten now as good as
requiem for heavy weight was or patterns
but
but because he was forced to write in
this wonderful
genre and write on universal themes fear
alienation you know loss of identity um
it just created these amazing stories
and his scripts are so good that they
would get the top actors actors who
often wouldn't do television and uh and
you got bernard herman and jerry
goldsmith these amazing composers and
george clemons this phenomenal uh
cinematographer it's just you look at
the best episodes of the twilight zone
and there are a lot of them
and you're just you hold your breath
they're so beautiful in every way
and timeless and
um and they work and even when you know
what the story is you're moved by these
people because rod had a genuine
sympathy and empathy
for the little guy for someone working
in as a bank teller or a woman who's a
secretary or you know he's not writing
generally about presidents or kings or
wealthy people uh he doesn't even though
he himself was one of the best paid
writers in television he's not fawning
he doesn't um
idolize the rich like some writers have
he's some he's a regular guy he's a you
know he's you can get the sense that he
has this big heart he really cares
deeply and he's coming from the heart
and again when i was talking a few
minutes ago about authenticity you know
rod when you see rod sterling on
television he's exactly that guy i mean
i've seen videos of him teaching classes
where he wasn't he knew these wouldn't
be broadcast and he was absolutely
himself warm and funny and smart and and
caring
and uh and that really comes across on
twilight zone this is a man saying
here's a story i want to tell and i'm
sharing it with you or here's these
other writers that i've brought aboard
who have these wonderful stories to
share with you it's his gift to the
audience and
it holds up because it's not
about something trivial the twilight
zone is about something profound deeply
profound and its meaning conveys to the
younger generation as much as to the
audience it was made for back in 1959.
have you seen every episode oh yeah
okay what would you say the top five
i've actually when i when i started
writing the twilight zone it was two
year twilight zone companion it was two
years after rod's death and carol
sterling his widow
was still living in the house in pacific
palisades his dog was there this irish
setter and all these
everything was exactly as he'd left
there was one room that was just the
awards the six emmys and the peabody
awards and on and on um and so in the
garage there were film cans his film
cans of twilight zone episode 16
millimeter prints it was part of his
contract that he would get two prints of
every episode because there's no vcrs
there was no home recording back then
so often i would go home with a stack of
these film cans and put them on the
projector and they had the original
commercials in the original coming
attraction spots and many of these had
never even been put through a projector
they were just pristine they were
gorgeous and
so yeah and there were
four episodes that weren't in
syndication and then there was an uh a
season and 18 episodes that were
hour-long episodes that weren't
generally syndicated they every now and
then they'd pop up but um yeah i i had
to do a little bit of uh pursuing some
of these episodes that were not in the
uh in the general audience though one of
the funniest stories in that regard was
that i uh i was researching the twilight
zone companion and this was just as vcrs
were starting to become available for
purchase but they weren't widely
available so i recorded the episodes off
the air on reels real tape i'm on
cassette tape and rod didn't have copies
of every episode it got more and more
hit and miss as the seasons went on and
so at one point they were like i think
two episodes that i could just not two
or three episodes that they just never
aired on ktla so which was syndicating
twilight zone so i called the station
manager
and i said listen i'm doing a book on
on the twilight zone and i there's three
episodes i need to see and i want to
find out when you're going to be airing
them because i really need to see them
he said well which episodes are they and
i told him he said well
we'll broadcast them next week so all of
la watched the episodes just because i
needed to see them oh wow
i thought he was going to just have me
in and maybe screen them for me but nope
everybody got to see him and so that was
that was really funny and wonderful but
uh but it was great that i was able to
do to produce the blu-ray set and do 52
commentaries and and now of course i'm
going to do the the rest of them 104
that are left and so people will be able
to buy buy all of them so they'll be
able to hear everything i know about
twilight zone and
for all of the episodes it's gonna be
great fun
if you had to choose what would be the
top five
i love walking distance which was rod's
personal favorite it's about a man who
goes back in time to his own childhood
it's a wonderful episode
um on thursday we leave for home which
is a great episode that rod wrote with
james whitmore it's one of the hour ones
uh i have the i the beholder which is
the woman whose head is wrapped in
bandages waiting to see if she's been
made to look normal
um
nightmare twenty thousand feet which is
the gremlin on the wing with william
shatner that richard donna directed it's
a great episode um i mean i could i
could list 20. i mean and um it's a good
life with billy mummy that's a great one
where he's got the power to do to
terrorize a small town
but again i could easily pick you know
death ship miniature there's so there's
so so many in praise of pip um
you know there's just it just goes on
and on time of the last with burgess
meredith as the last man on earth um
there's just i mean week after week
after week after week it was an
astonishing
artistic feat what he was what he was
pulling off it was
no one has ever really equaled it i
don't think
i mean i've been very very lucky because
i met elaine when i was
i think i just turned 20 and so that was
perfection that was great because again
when she met me i was just a little
college student there was no telling if
i would accomplish anything and she had
faith in me you know so i i mean when i
met her i already knew she was wonderful
but you know she was taking a big risk
in me uh and it worked out but but i've
been very lucky because you know think
of all the people who
as kids they want to be writers or
directors or or producers they watch tv
shows they say god i'd like to be part
of that world i want to be on the other
side of the glass of the tv screen and i
got to do that i got to be that i mean
my heroes were rod sterling and ray
bradbury because they were doing tv and
books and movies and i got to do all of
that